هو طبعا انت عملت في المجتمع لخمسه عقود
لخمسين عاما لنصف قرن ثم عملت في الدوله
لثلاثه عقود لثلاثين عاما فهذه تجربه
مكتمله انت جربت هذه الشعارات وهذه
الافكار في المجتمع وجربتها في الدوله
وانتهت الى باوار الى خيبه وعندئذ اي حركه
انسانيه تعيد النظر بعمق وبتجرد كامل لتصد
اخطائها ثم لتنفذ الى رؤيه جديده وهذه
المرحله التي انا دعوت الى ان تكون هي
مرحله قطيعه نفسيه ومعرفيه لانه قلت ان
هذا التيار تاسس قبل اكثر من قرن مع
الافغانس السياسي لانه افغاني تلميذه محمد
عبده محمد عبده تلميذو رشيد رضا ورشيد رضا
تلميذه البنا هذه حركه الاحياء التي بدات
منذ ذلك الوقت في تونس حدث اجتهاد جيد لا
باس به حاول ان يفصل الدعوي عن السياسي
ولم يكن لانه اي انسان يريد ان يتصدى
لتحويل المجتمع الى مجتمع اسلامي عليه ان
يجيب على اسئله المناهج الحديثه التي بحثت
في القران وبحثت في الحديث وبحثت في
الحاله الحضاريه كلها منذ مالك النبي انه
هنالك حاله حضاريه انا كنت اريد ان اشير
الى مثل بسيط انهم ارادوا ان يمولوا
استدماوي ولكن القروض كانت ربويه فعندما
او تصوروا انها الربويه بالمعنى الربا في
مكه والمدينه فذهبوا الى مجمع الفقه
الاسلامي وقال ان هذا حرام وكانوا يريدون
ان يبنوا بايما طريقه فعقدوا مؤتمر
اقتصادي الذين قدموا اوراق في المؤتمر
قالوا ان هذا كان اصعب شيء عليهم انه
يريدون هذه القروض الدوليه واسهل لشيء كان
عليهم ان يقارنوا بين الربا واحكامه التي
كانت تتطور والقران ينزل وبين الاقتصاد
السياسي
والمعاصله الكثيف فلم يست طيع ان يقوموا
بهذه الاجتهادات لانهم لم يكملوا مراحل
القطيعه المعرفيه والنفسيه مع تاريخ الفقه
الاسلامي ومع ماضي الاسلام السياسي